[Music]
this article that i came across is
fascinating it's from wtop local news in
washington dc and here's the headline
that grabbed me
can you buy cryptocurrency with a credit
card oh hooray
the answer spoiler alert is yes yes
and uh
this is what uh one of the financial
professionals here that's interviewed
steve larsen he's a co-founder of
planner dao cryptocurrency education
community for financial planners he
actually teaches classes on this stuff
and they said much of the chagrin of
some financial
professionals and here's what he said if
you wouldn't buy shares of apple stock
on your credit card you shouldn't be
putting putting bitcoin on your card
either yet many people do so
every day
and so the article goes on to talk about
how depending on your card issuer and
the cryptocurrency exchange platform you
can in fact use a credit card go into
debt to buy cryptocurrency
this is frightening times we live in
john wow you can't just buy single
stocks you can use imaginary money to
buy and that imaginary pieces of
imaginary money
my mind just exploded is that incredible
or what incredible in a bad way this is
frightening wow
and here's what it turns out to be there
are so many fees involved with this
process uh coinmama is one of the
exchange platforms where you can do this
you can use your credit card to buy it
and they charge a transaction fee based
on the market rate which can fluctuate
plus two percent they also have a
commission of up to three point nine
percent and an additional five percent
fee if you choose to buy with a credit
card so let's say you wanna buy a
thousand dollars worth of crypto we're
gonna pay a hundred and nine dollars in
fees alone yeah only to possibly lose it
all anyways so here's what it feels like
to me
um
if i'm the average person at home i'm
hearing about crypto i'm hearing about
i'm hearing about it i'm looking at some
of the world's wealthiest men and women
saying dude you got to get in on this
get in on this i've created my own i've
created my own i got my own platform my
platform's gotta feed is your platform
have a fee when my platform will talk
i'm just feeling like
i'm getting behind like everybody's got
a smartphone without except for me
everybody's got a car with gas and i'm
still in my horse right
and so
they're making it easier and easier and
easier for us and we're feel we feel
like we're missing more and more out on
things
i love going back to man nobody's hating
on crypto going back to if you're if
you're trying to buy crypto as a hedge
against a monetary policy that's when
you're a bonkers that's a whole other
phone call but
but if you wouldn't buy stock
if you wouldn't go invest in your
friend's company on a credit card like
if you wouldn't make that kind of
nonsensical move
don't buy imaginary money
using imaginary money
well said on top of that this is
fascinating too the card issuer so the
credit card company on top of all those
fees i mentioned
they treat this as a cash advance and so
that comes with much higher interest
rates and a five percent cash advance
fee and so they go on to talk about the
pros and cons and hilariously this is
one of the pros they mention
you can invest without having the cash
on hand
that's real that is a recipe for a
financial disaster
that's gambling on a credit card if you
wouldn't go to vegas well people go to
vegas and credit cards all the time so i
don't know at least vegas is
entertaining there you go but they also
mentioned this is a pro you can
potentially earn rewards on your
investment you can get credit card
rewards john
i can't stop doing it miles
this is genius we're hacking the system
so listen if you feel like you are
missing out
and you don't have you may be let's be
you may be
but if you don't have money
you can't afford it
john that hurt my feelings i know it
does and you only have three of them
left i only have so many left that's
right
don't buy something you have no money to
buy it
they do close in a way that makes me
happy here they talk about this crypto
is already a volatile investment and by
purchasing it with with credit as in
money you don't actually have it's a
sign you can't really afford to lose
that money this is from the news they're
actually saying this way to go news if
your crypto investment loses value it
compounds those losses and it ends with
this great quote from steve who they
interviewed i have found most people who
purchase crypto on credit aren't focused
on building a portfolio they're trying
to reduce their exposure to their least
favorite asset class
that's a mic drop from steve larsen way
to go steve don't let fear of missing
out plunge you into debt don't do this
i'm not mad at crypto if you want to do
it and here's what we tell people john
get out of debt have a fully funded
emergency fund be investing 15
into retirement that means 401ks iras
things rooted in reality
and then if you've got some fun money
that you want to spend you want to take
100 bucks and buy some doge or ethereum
or bitcoin or you want to take a
thousand bucks and that's money you're
willing to lose as in if you set that on
the table and lit it on fire you
wouldn't be too sad
you go well we had fun that's like vegas
right you bring 200 bucks to vegas you
play some slots you go home but it's
when people get in over their heads and
it becomes obsessive i mean this isn't
hobby this is and you get more expensive
than golfing yeah you get over leveraged
and it gets frightening yeah so do it
the right way
don't have the fomo have what i like to
call jomo the joy of missing out i love
not investing in crypto how long did it
take you to come up with jomo a few
years that's a work in progress that's
great it's not great all right you're
really talented i'm over two today john
that wasn't great i thought we were
having a good time but
turns out that we were having a great
time till you joe mode the whole segment
all right well that's crypto for you
folks